by the way you'll be careful what you're
saying now because these guys they're
filming
the youtube channel is obviously an
important medium for the cambridges
and up until now they've shared that
platform with the royal family so i
think it's quite significant that we've
seen them
branch away set up their own channel
and give them the emphasis that they are
now putting
on social media on videos this is really
important for them we're covering the
royal family in a very different way
today that's largely down to the
pandemic
we don't cover engagements the way we
used to we simply can't
have many of us on the ground covering
these engagements
so we're very dependent on the royals to
cover their engagements
and what they're up to through the
medium of video so this feels like a
very fitting time
to launch a channel and it was an
opportunity to
launch a lovely teaser in which you know
we saw william kate and some behind the
scenes
outtakes good morning royal highlands
good morning my goodness me you're super
light mila
and then today the duchess of cambridge
has posted a video of a telephone call
that she made with one of the subjects
from her hold still photographic
exhibition i think that shows how they
are planning
to use this medium to communicate to an
audience
i think specifically and importantly a
younger audience
we are seeing the royals work in a
different way
during this pandemic video has never
been
more important it makes them accessible
it's an
immediate way of communicating what
they're doing i think this is very
important for the cambridges to reach
out to a new demographic
essentially a younger audience they
realize the value of streaming
they've got a brilliant digital team
behind them we've seen more of them
i think at home relax in their own time
during the pandemic
through video conference calls and
videos that they've chosen to release
i think it's probably a coincidence that
we've had the duchess of cambridge
announce hold still a book about her
photographic exhibition
at the same time that the duchess of
sussex has announced her debut
children's book
but it might not be such a coincidence
that we are seeing the cambridges
launch a glossy new youtube channel
just after the sussexes have signed a
multi-million dollar deal
with spotify and netflix they are
tapping into
this streaming platform and possibly
they're looking to the sussexes
and thought yeah we need to be doing
this too but don't forget they will be
using
this social media platform in a very
different way
to megan and harry well you don't really
talk about brand within the royal family
but of course they are the most
successful brand in the world and
william and kate recognize that and i
think we are seeing them
rebranding to a degree so we learned
that megan has
penned a children's book called the
bench its
inspiration was a poem that she wrote to
prince harry on father's day
about his relationship with their son
archie we've seen a few excerpts from it
we've seen some of the beautiful
illustrations
and i think megan is a great writer
i know that writing books is something
that she has aspired to for a long time
well there are lots of rumors flying
around about how much megan received um
seven hundred thousand dollars is one of
the figures i think that sounds pretty
high but
it's fair to say that she is going to
have received a sizable advance and that
is largely because of the name on the
front page
megan duchess of sussex i mean that name
is going to earn her
a big advance and i think this will
probably be
the first of several books to come in
the future
you